so what we were trying to do was design
a spreadsheet that could work out how
much tax you would pay on whatever
income okay so i'm just going to flash
this up to show you because it's a bit
too complicated to um actually get you
guys to do it and there's not that much
point because calculators exist that do
this uh this is the um
this is the cell that we need to muck
around with okay now if you go to where
that cell is on yours you should be able
to open it up and it should have um a
formula in it which had this kind of
thing
something like
this uh
it's
from memory
no other way
i think this is what we had um 0.19
times
okay so i'm doing this sort of memory
but i'm pretty sure that's what you have
okay for those of you who didn't um
catch that what was happening was we're
checking to see if your income was less
than a certain
threshold namely
this one okay 18 200 if it's less than
that then you don't pay any tax
but if it's not less than that if it's
higher then you will pay some tax namely
19 cents for every dollar over that
amount and that's what that formula is
all about doing all that calculating
okay
now unfortunately this is too simple it
doesn't deal with all of the tax
brackets only deals with these two okay
so i'm just going to show you quickly
what it would look like if it dealt with
all of them
now this is you can see why now i'm not
going to get you to do this right now
but you can actually see if you don't
type it out what's going on okay can you
see it starts off in exactly the same
way
if b10 every time you see b10 and it
comes up a lot of times right b10 is
just how much you're earning right
if that's less than 80 200 you pay no
tax so far so good okay
but then what happens here right i have
to start saying if again
because if you're not earning less than
18 200 then you might be earning a whole
bunch of different things and i need to
work out which one you're in okay so if
you see
how many times it says if
can you count
i've got one
two
three
four
four that's it okay the four
ifs are trying to work out is it this or
this
is it this or this is it this or this
and it does it four times right because
there are four different things that i
have to compare okay so if you want to
have a look at how i actually
constructed that then i can show you
more detail later
but that's basically how you would do it
and now whatever income is in here your
gross income it'll work out the right
tax for you okay